una necesidad de ayuda humanitaria que
aumenta año tras año este miércoles el
secretario general de asuntos
humanitarios de la ONU Machine WiFi
anunció que la organización pedirá un
25% más de financiación para 2023 para
llevar a cabo operaciones de ayuda
humanitaria en todo el mundo y así va a
subir alrededor del 25% Y eso es
impactante Pero ha subido cada año un
25% en los últimos años Así que lo que
esto significa es muy muy simple y es
una simple suma de hecho que la brecha
entre las necesidades y la financiación
va a crecer pero cada año y a pesar de
las demandas alarmantes de la ONU la
financiación está lejos de alcanzar el
presupuesto necesario entre los países
más necesitados están somalia y Etiopía
donde aunque no se ha declarado
oficialmente la hambruna sus habitantes
están muriendo de hambre por las sequías
la invasión rusa a Ucrania también
contribuyó al aumento de la humanitaria
además de haber las
exportaciones ucranianas de grano al mar
Negro también detuvo un óleoducto que
transportaba armoníaco un ingrediente
clave para los fertilizantes
en la industria de la seguridad
alimentaria si no utilizamos
fertilizantes ahora tendremos un
problema de disponibilidad de alimentos
dentro de un año Así que es enormemente
importante casi más importante que el
grano entre los otros países en
situación de alta vulnerabilidad está
organizando donde la mitad de la
población depende de la ayuda
humanitaria o yemen y Siria que sufren
guerras desde hace años